Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent,
do you farm
exciting stuff going on?
Gene always in this house.
She's,
hello.
Sounds make a deal.
I'll be in a ball.
Sacramento this weekend.
Shows are sold out.
Thank you guys very much.
Um,
ball sack.
Next week I'm doing a big thing with the Joe Rogan.
He's celebrating his 1000 thousand thousand thousand thousand citizens.
1000th episode of the Joe Rogan experience.
Wow.
Can you believe that?
That's incredible.
The pod father,
the guy,
the guy who did like the very first episode ever of any podcast,
it's not crazy stuff.
1000 episodes,
bananas.
He's having myself and Joey Diaz on.
Oh my God.
That's going to be a crazy pie guy.
And then a celebration show that night at the comedy store,
which sold out in like three minutes.
Oh my gosh.
That'll be next Friday the 18th.
Uh,
what else?
We have a live podcast,
August 23rd in brass balls,
beach,
Florida.
If you're in Palm Beach County,
Broward County,
Dade County,
Indian River County,
please come to the Palm Beach Bim Prov
then things ramp up for me.
Brett.
Before I shoot my special,
I added a show at the Brayer Improv a couple of nights before.
So Wednesday,
September 13th,
I'm doing the Bray Improv one show only the next night I'm doing Oakland,
the Fox theater.
And then I shoot in Denver on the 16th.
Very excited.
Um,
first show is sold out.
The second show is like 200 tickets left.
So if you're in Denver and you haven't gotten tickets yet,
you want to go,
I recommend getting them now so you get your special tape.
That's pretty special.
It would be very special.
I'm also doing Lincoln,
Nebraska,
Springfield,
Missouri and Midwest City,
Oklahoma earlier in the month.
And we added a second shows in Fargo,
North Dakota,
saint loose tits,
Missoura and um,
I'm coming to Ju Dork titties.
Barthalow there's a bunch of things at it.
So go to Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
Check out all the dates that are there.
Gene,
a gene you mentioned August 23rd and breast Palm Beach.
That's good guys.
Come and see that work.
Also,
those are moving very quickly.
So if you are considering it,
I would highly advise getting them now because were you don't have many left.
September 22nd and 23rd I'm in Saint Louis.
Ted's Missoura,
helium comedy Kreb or should I say hearing them is Kim Mann would say
October 3rd Nashville,
Tennessee at [inaudible] comedy club,
October 4th in Charlotte,
North Carolina at the comedy zone and then October 8th we're doing your mom's
house live in sperm via we have it to make a correction.
Sorry,
that wasn't your fault.
You made it logical assumption which was that if you had tickets to the July
Irvine Improv podcasts that they transferred.
They did.
Not Everyone was refunded.
So if you want to go to the October 8th Irvine,
your mom's house live,
you got to get tickets.
They are at the bottom of my tour page.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com slash tour scroll all the way to the bottom,
it says live podcasts.
You can get tickets to either west palm or Irvine there.
That's right.
Oh and tickets for my shows are on thousand ranch.com or you can go to
Christina.
He online.com all the both of those URLs go to the same place.
Doing a little image overhaul before my special comes out.
Making the change to going to be,
it's going to be safe.
I can't announce it yet.
It's so annoying.
Hopefully soon we can make a formal announcement,
but it's coming.
Good,
Mike.
I can hear the chips in the bowl.
That package is opening and it's almost ready to be poured in the bowl.
It's really accept firework are horn.
Very exciting.
Welcome to another episode of Your Mom's house.
Let's get into this show.
Okay,
let's do it.
Oh Jeez.
Phone
real.
You guys are doing good.
That is the Moose Soup Remix,
uh,
by Matt Mercer has excellent,
you know,
we,
we went on a little three day vacation with the little jeans,
just a local here and we couldn't get her out of our hearts.
The most soup lady came with us and we had to play her and rob,
we had,
we listened to our own show just to hear the drop.
Oh yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
We were like finding this stuff from,
from the,
that like scrolling through it,
trying to find out,
you know,
like what,
what was said and hearing,
hearing it again just in real time.
Yeah.
Part is that because you,
you did the drop of you guys are doing good but you cut out the fuck and now to
hear the fuck you guys are doing good.
It's even,
it's even more trashy.
It's even better.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Um,
we even,
by the way,
this is not something we normally do.
Let me see if I can,
uh,
pull this up.
So we had,
we've had like all these great designs come in.
Uh,
and this one was also sent in the moose soup men's black tee shirt.
So somebody may call it dark one with a soup can on it,
but it's a brilliant design and it says the mill,
the moose soup lady.
So that's also in our store.
Thank you.
Everybody who's been supporting,
they got the rub rub shirt.
Ah,
sorry.
Makes you very uncomfortable.
Hot Seller for the ladies.
Uh,
yeah,
I got a number of interesting messages about that.
Um,
people got the uh,
yeah,
the,
the rub rub shirt.
The uh,
come down from moose soup shirt.
Um,
sorry that was wrong.
Uh,
the sub Cain,
the new rob,
Rob,
rob.
That was the,
uh,
this is the one that dose Brac made a Irish designer.
I just wore this this morning.
I'm making fitness.
I wore this morning.
I did.
Yeah.
No,
we love the moose soup ladies so much.
Yeah,
we have two minutes.
We have two shirts dedicated to her.
It's good.
Too good.
But she's too good.
And the designs are too good to not do them.
So thank you guys for,
um,
for supporting the store silliness.
Ridiculous.
I think we lose money on these shirts.
Just make them,
yeah.
Yeah.
Uh,
somebody said that there's nothing quite as PTSD and do things as the rub rub
guy.
I have to agree.
There's nothing like that guys who I don't like him.
I don't like him as much as I liked the moose suit lady.
Well,
no,
she's great.
You guys are doing good.
Uh,
all right,
let's do it.
Official Open,
right?
Yeah,
let's do it all ready.
And I first read,
I suspect in 2014 when I was having sex with my girlfriend,
I noticed that she had this really strong smell of os and I really liked it.
I found it really enjoyable and arousing.
It kind of smelled like this rich odor of body sweats combined with the smell of
shit.
Basically.
How old is Randy?
Don't bring anyone loving to them.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house with Tom.
Christina.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
No one you now,
Huh?
You know,
you put a tree in your mouth and then halfway through it you're like,
I don't want to commit to this.
Yeah,
I know exactly what you're talking about.
I just did that.
Now I don't think I want it,
but I'm going to do it.
Ever since I lost some weight.
I always think about whether I like what I'm eating or whether I'm just eating
to eat right.
Is it worth the calorie?
I just also,
I'm like,
I used to be like,
this isn't that good,
but I'll eat the whole thing.
Like that's how I used to just walk through everything.
Yeah.
Like a dog.
Like,
it's all right.
I'll finish it.
No,
this is okay.
But I'm still gonna go through it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it'd be,
you know,
really calorically and sugar rich and I'd be like,
yeah,
man,
just eat it.
It's like a dog.
Like they can't refuse a tree,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
I just,
I should have just put that out,
but I don't have anywhere to put it.
I could've put it in my hand on my part and then put it in my pocket in your
pocket.
Next.
Done that before.
Oh,
you're fucking with the other friends of your pocket friends.
So this kid,
um,
he's a blogger and I have to say,
you know,
I commend him for his honesty.
Uh,
my,
I think the,
the general,
you know,
the,
the inclination of people when they hear that right away,
it'd be like,
Oh,
you nasty as hell.
Course some y'all was just nasty.
And he talks about being attracted to the ass bump,
but I think it's a pretty common one actually.
Well,
it must be on a evolutionary biological level,
and there's a reason our bodies produce pheromones and different smells.
And to some people of y'all is nasty.
He's healed.
Yeah.
So he's found his ideal mate perhaps.
Who makes that smell and they're going to reproduce and make other children who
stick,
make nasty smells nasty babies.
But I've met,
I've talked to dude's before who are into like funky smells,
you know?
Sure.
Well guys are disgusting too.
That was going to say,
but I wonder,
I mean there's got to be some women that are into the funky smell,
right?
No,
none.
I mean,
I've never had a friend that admitted to it.
I'm sure there are guys would admit to it more.
Yeah.
Yeah,
there's gotta be,
but the women are just less nasty.
I know.
You are less nasty.
There's definitely way more dudes that are like,
I like a funky ass hole.
It's not on the menu for most of us ladies.
Yeah.
Well I mean I,
okay,
let's put the call out.
Are there any ladies out there who love the smell of a ripe guy ass
or any ladies that are lesbians?
Maybe you like about smells
but smells.
Maybe that's thinky but smells disgusting.
But it smells really nice to me.
I really liked the smell.
Is that weird?
We start normal because the smell of shits shouldn't be nice.
It shouldn't be pleasant.
They shit disgusting and repulse people because Shit isn't nice.
It's disgusting and foot of bacteria.
You don't want to get anywhere near that stuff.
Well,
I think there's an important distinction to be made here is that I don't think
he is necessarily aroused by shit curves aroused by the mix of this Musk of
sweat.
Right.
And there's,
there's some but
in there.
Right.
And that's what's turning him on.
It's not just a dump sitting in the toilet.
Well that's a really important distinction really is though.
It's like we,
it's like our revelation of shits.
Push the farts out not far to push the shit out.
Mistakenly we're saying for years,
years.
Well,
my mother gave me that wisdom and flats,
Bush the shutout,
and that's all I heard going up.
It's almost like your mother was a flat earthers and then somebody just kind of
explained it to you.
Like it doesn't work that way.
It's not that far.
It's push the shit up.
One of our listeners actually opened our eyes and our buttholes too real.
And that's another one that you and I have been talking about this last week
together is that it's the shit that pushes the farts out.
And I just kind of blew my mind til kind of blew it.
Well there are,
you know what,
uh,
I guess it's people's body smells you,
you like,
it's that person's pheromones mixed in with whatever.
He must really be into this girl.
But it could be,
I mean,
yes,
but also like you can have that,
that attraction to someone you don't know.
Right.
He could just be like,
oh,
I like,
I guess this person smells.
Yeah.
I've also been repulsed by the way,
stranger,
just like their body smells,
you know,
repulsion.
I've had manufactured smell repulsion from perfumes,
colognes,
fucking Pachulia oil,
petroleum oil.
That's my least favorite man.
If you were one of those chicks,
it be no boners in this house.
Well cause perpetually growing up,
growing up when I went to San Francisco for college,
if that girl wore.
But truly it meant that she didn't wash her beaver very often.
Like those were always the dirtiest of the girls that had Pachulia,
Eh hmm.
Interesting.
It was really no spill.
Every time we had sex,
doggy style,
and every time I thrusted forwards,
the smell would waft upwards into my nostrils.
And it was Rudy arousing.
I really enjoyed the smell.
I don't know why she had such a strong smell of ass because you should ego a
stone house,
strong smell because they wash properly down there after they've taken a shit.
So true.
I'm not sure if she wasn't washing properly after she took a shit,
but I wasn't complaining because I said,
yeah,
I really enjoy life now.
So good for you man.
I can see that relationship.
I always check to see if the girl has this same smell.
But none of them do because they usually wash,
wash that area.
Yep.
So that was like his special mistress.
That was a snowflake and he let it get away.
He left that stinky bottle.
Don't let that Brown dirty girl to get away wasn't necessarily washing.
Well that's true.
No,
she didn't.
She wasn't.
Yeah.
Really?
So she was just not white or she has leaky,
but leaky boat was just something that I talk about a lot on this show and the
importance of shit to shower or getting a bad day of some sort.
She could be shitting and then not cleaning up properly and,
and having leaky,
but,
and then if you're having sex and then it Kinda all mixes in down there.
Yeah,
I like that.
You just be swamp ass.
Maybe these are never smelled my,
my bud.
Never.
You don't want to no,
no,
no.
Never.
No.
Do you smell your own bottle lot?
No,
but I'm sure it's not nice.
It's disgusting.
I mean,
you can give it a shot if you want it.
Nope.
Until there's no smell left,
which I find to be really disappointing.
It's really boring when the goal smells like nothing.
Yeah.
Smell is a big part of sex for me.
And if the goal smells like nothing,
she has no body odor.
It was kind of boring.
I agree with him.
Yeah.
I don't want,
I mean,
out of the shower.
Yuck.
Give me,
let me know that you're,
uh,
you're doing some work and building your mosque.
Yeah.
Build that Musk.
There was a real Musk builder at that gym.
I used to go,
woof,
I remember it.
I do with fal and it was like a message to the rest of the gym to the bears.
Yeah,
I'm here.
Smell my funk.
He was nasty.
But there's probably dudes walking around that Jim like,
ah,
fuck.
That dude stinks.
So good.
Anyway,
as I came in thinking about this is what I can see our son doing this blog,
this,
Oh god,
I hope not.
He will to this kind of thing.
Well,
he's got two parents and I know that's true.
I don't like having sex with girls after they've had a shower because they've
washed away all that delicious odor and smell pretty shallow sex.
It's just so much better than just shower sec.
I just said it totally right.
100%.
And do you remember that Iranian girl that I met last year and yeah.
Yeah,
the one that I asked if she wanted to have sex with me and she said No.
Well,
one of the main reasons why I felt so attracted to her,
it wasn't because I thought she was pretty or cute.
It was because she had this amazing smell of armpits.
Every time she sat next to me and my room,
I could smell this strong,
rich,
bitter smell of armpit,
and it was really a rousing here.
So he likes more than just certain.
He likes a lot of stinky stuff.
They should have just asked if I could smell her armpit instead of asking for
sex.
But then if I smelled her armpit,
I would have been even more aroused and turned on and it would have wanted to
have sex even more.
This channel was getting kind of weird,
isn't it?
I celebrate you,
sir.
You always tell me,
you're like,
I've never smelled.
You never smell.
Yeah,
it's true.
I'm serious.
In how long?
38 years we've been together.
I've never gotten a whiff of bio from you.
What about Trish?
Trish is a little stinky.
She's got that wine mouth.
Yeah.
Karen too.
The both of them cigarettes.
Barflies Marlboro reds.
Yeah.
Moose soup.
Oh yeah.
Both kind of moose soup type of chicks for sure.
Yeah,
that's definitely,
definitely your speed.
Dirty pic.
So stupid.
Um,
so I did a what?
Yeah,
what are you talking about your appearance last night?
That's what I was bringing.
Okay.
Um,
I did um,
Conan.
Is that how you say it?
That's funny that that's his name.
Yeah.
Meet many Conan's I have a,
I had a really fun time doing the show and I got to,
I won't play the whole thing,
but I did get to sneak this in to the top of the show or the top of the
interview and he's like,
Oh,
you look great and I'll let you hear the beginning of it.
It's pretty good.
You did great by the way.
The whole thing is on.
Thank you very much,
man.
Thanks.
I lost 50 pounds,
50 pounds.
Everyone wants to know how one does that because everyone's obsessed.
What was your trick?
Everybody's been there.
I was in a weight loss contest with this super fat comic named Bernd Chrysler
and
very crazy.
Got a burnt in there.
Yeah,
I did.
Does he know yet?
Uh,
I don't know if he knows.
He's gonna know.
Conan definitely knew what I was doing.
He did because it's like there's a pre interview and I told the producer,
I was like,
imma call him burnt.
I go,
you know,
if you want to tell Conan to correct me and be like,
oh is that bird or you know,
I go,
that's,
that's fine.
Or whatever.
I mean,
you know,
obviously you can do whatever he wants and so,
but he,
he definitely went like shook his head like,
yeah,
I know.
What we did was we did a couple of people I think knew what was up.
I think you're right.
I think some mommies were in the audience because they laughed at top dog stuff
too.
Yes,
yes.
So anyways,
you can go to team Coco.
I don't play a clip after clip of that,
but team Coco,
um,
dot com or the youtube team coco page
and you can see it if you want.
You talk about top dog,
talk about a little jeans and uh,
weight loss and we'd talk about,
we'd talk about Ya.
Um,
uh,
our little gene learning different languages and top dog.
Yeah,
it's a very good appearance.
I thought you said really well thanks.
And I also liked your outfit.
You look very fresh,
fresh and clean.
I had a fresh haircut,
which is important for television.
He looked great.
Yeah,
Conan and,
and how funny is Andy Tell I love him.
He's great.
He's fantastic.
He's really,
really great.
Uh,
somebody sent speaking a top dog this talking Dildo,
embarrassed that they said sounds just like top dog.
You want to see it?
Yeah.
So does this sound like top dog to you?
God.
Did Your Dad do this?
Does that sound like him to do a blue band was like,
dude,
this thing sounds like to me,
I think it's a little different.
Like my ear is so tuned to voice.
It's pretty similar.
I think so.
Yeah.
I could pass for him.
Very nice
to hear.
This is what you owe and the voice is an older gentleman.
He sounds like 50 press or 60 press and if you're using one of those,
you're probably not 60 or 50 press woman.
What do you want to hear though?
I don't know.
I don't want to hear anything that you're doing that you don't want to hear a
man?
No,
I don't need to.
I don't want to hear anything.
But if you were to hear a man,
would you want them to be like,
I don't.
I don't know.
I Dunno.
Why did you shave so much pool?
I'm going to follow up
weird toy.
I don't know why it needs the voice.
It's a little bit,
I mean I'm sure somebody out there.
I was like,
that's perfect for me.
It's always like that.
Just like that's sticky buttholes for somebody.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
You
picture my dad when you hear that I kind of kit,
especially since last time we learned that he likes Lacy Bras,
which is disgusting.
I told that on Conan.
Yeah.
Let me see through the nipple and throw up
and other stuff.
I nasty.
So nasty.
I ain't know it gives your dad a boner.
I know.
Gross.
So weird to hear his boner stories.
No,
I don't think I'd want my vibrator to talk about anything.
Why does it have to have any kind of conversation with you?
I don't know.
I mean I definitely,
I don't think it does it for me to have.
If it was a toy that was like,
oh baby,
you're so hard.
I wouldn't be like,
yeah,
this is great.
It's kind of like real fake,
you know?
I would,
I would think it would take me out of it more.
Yeah,
me too.
It'd be really distracting.
Like,
why is this guy telling me this stuff?
Like you don't say that in real life to somebody like,
oh,
your breasts are so full and wow,
your touches so soft.
Like,
I don't know.
I don't really,
I never had a guy said to me in real life,
I'd be like,
what?
Why are you talking about my dad very ready to explode.
And it's like an old guy boys too.
It's not even shit ain't right.
Nasty.
Assuming it was two men.
Super Nasty.
Anyway,
so we went away on our,
our little mini vacay with our little jeans,
just the three of us.
And I noticed a phenomenon,
um,
amongst the couples,
which we've been talking about this a lot on the show is the shut it down look
and well for dads the shut it down is generally,
I mean,
what would you say?
Shut it down.
Dad is the white new balance sneakers.
I'm talking Khakis or maybe some light colored denim with some brown braided
belt.
It's buttoned down.
Over,
it's over.
It's one testosterone just leaves the body.
And then for the women,
I think motherhood can shut us down and that's when the ladies cut their hair
off or let it go gray.
And then there's like a cool lots and it's important to note that neither has to
happen though to either.
That's the whole point is the struggle is real though.
You really do have to fight to maintain your sexuality and your sex appeal to
your spouse.
Especially as you get older.
You see people shut it down in their thirties forties 50s and stuff for sure.
But you can see the shutdown.
Yeah,
I saw it man.
You're like 30 years old
and there was like this Nick Attractive Late Thirties gentlemen and he was
dressed like cool.
Like he still had like shorts on.
He was,
he had his beard trend line.
Like he would look to youthful and the wife had totally shut it down.
Like she had short hair like you,
I was all gray and that gray grayed out and then like,
like kind of dress like you right now,
like a polo shirt and then like khaki shorts and then the Jesus animals.
Oh Man.
And you could just see the sadness in his eyes.
Like he,
you know,
he was looking at it like other women
walked by.
I like,
oh,
that's what a woman I remember.
I remember that when I met you.
I liked you like that,
but now you're not into a boners anymore.
It's so sad.
But what,
but here's what the thing is that like there's the shut it down phenomenon.
We're only one person shuts it down.
And then the other person,
like it's really well maintained.
So like what's going on there?
When one person that's called the path to divorce the windows,
sometimes I think it's actually fetishized.
Interesting.
Smeller kid there.
Cause I know,
I don't know about it the other way as much,
but I know some dudes that really like,
you know,
I mean at least really big women.
Yeah.
So that could be perceived as like,
oh,
does that person not care?
But actually they're turned on by it.
They're really into heavy set.
Yeah.
That's totally big old flappy sloppy roles.
You know what I mean?
That's a,
that's a turn on for some people.
Well one time you and I were in The Bahamas somewhere and we saw this couple and
then the dude was like ripped.
He was like 150 pounds.
Just,
just,
there's wasn't an ounce of anything extra really.
Well,
totally ripped.
I had the six pack abs.
Yeah.
Looking good.
She was for bills.
Really?
No,
she was very large.
Yeah.
And she was like,
oh man.
Oh Man.
She uh,
she needed,
she called him over to pick her up from the,
she had like sat in the,
where the waves break never forget,
I will never forget
is I got to get up and he had to pick her and he had to like use all of his body
weight strength to get her up.
I'll never forget it because she was sitting like in the shallows of the ocean
and the waves kept pushing her inland and she was kind of riding those waves
cause she couldn't stand up.
It was like too hard for her.
Yeah,
she was huge man.
I'll never forget the image of him pulling,
like pulling her up and I thought,
wow,
what's happening?
Like what do you think this was a slow progression.
And he was like,
on this particular couple while it could be that like,
oh he loves her or he's doing,
he's seemed broken.
I remember that guy.
He didn't,
there was,
there was no joy in his face.
You know,
everything about the way he carried himself like a sad man.
Beaten dog.
Yeah.
It wasn't,
it wasn't Michael Hart.
I don't think maybe my,
I won't know unless I talk to him and reach down his pants.
But,
uh,
I felt like he was not the time that was like,
this is what we're really into.
This,
it seemed like,
it's interesting.
She was a,
uh,
I almost picked up that she was abusive.
That was my version of her fatness was a form of abuse to him.
That's what it seemed like to me.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Oh yeah.
How did we not think about this when we,
uh,
we're playing this smell,
smell luck.
And there's again guys,
no women in there.
There's no,
no,
there's no women in it.
Run your finger along the crack of your ass.
You don't need to finger your whole,
you don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
No.
Shit.
Dummy.
That's a very interesting advice.
Stupid.
Who says that?
That guy,
that dog trainer,
that pup play master.
I want to fucking asshole.
I love that.
In that thing,
he's like,
I'm just trying to train these dogs,
but he's like really doing a service to people.
Uh,
just so you know,
coming up in a little bit here,
we will have the great miss pat joining us.
She has a new book coming out
and it's a called rabbit.
We both got copies of it.
We'll be talking to her very shortly.
Um,
it's excite.
Uh,
she's got quite a life story.
Crazy story.
Great comic.
Uh,
very,
very funny.
If you ever have a chance to see miss pat,
I would definitely go get it.
She is fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
She's really easily to la.
Where's she?
She's in India.
I think she's an Indiana,
not India.
Yeah,
but yeah.
So she's what you saw that you said India Indi.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She doesn't live in India.
You think I've met,
that's what I thought I was saying.
Bombay.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
She was like a Punjabi.
No.
Can I read you an email?
Yeah,
please.
So yeah,
I thought this was very thought provoking and I,
I always want to bring these emails to your attention and to the collective
consciousness.
Okay.
What's up jeans?
My wife and I were laying in bed when all of a sudden I farted and it sounded
like a Queef.
This raised the question,
why is it called a Queef?
Queef doesn't really fit.
My wife's suggestion was a fussy affording pussy,
but I think it should be called blower cause it just sounds like air.
We all enjoy.
Oh,
we will enjoy our moose soup while waiting for the answer.
Keep it high and tight.
Hitler's Eric,
I'm a little confused.
Fart.
Yeah,
he farted and it sounded like a Queef.
Oh.
Which led them to the thinking of why is it called a Queef?
Queef doesn't really fit.
Yeah.
Wait a minute though.
But he just farted.
But FARC can sound like a queef.
Right.
But I mean if,
if he farted,
right,
it's still just a fart.
I mean fart sound different all the time.
It's still,
it is called a fart.
Yes.
But then it got them to thinking because it sounded like a queef not a fart.
I understand that.
Oh,
what I'm saying is anytime anybody farts and you fart out of your buffalo,
I say it's just a fart.
I mean this doesn't matter if it,
it can sound like any number of things.
Right.
Why would you give it a different label though?
Cause it sounds different.
No,
no,
no.
So he,
that's not the question.
The question is why is a queef called a queef not what is a fart?
That sounds like a cliche if we've called a queef correct.
Like it doesn't seem to match a pussy fart is what a Queef so he's saying it
should be called a fussy.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Right.
Like why is it called that?
And I mean I have a theory,
I was thinking about this to hear it.
I'm real excited.
The British word for Virgin Fanny Quim Right.
Or a fanny.
Fanny Fart.
But Quim right.
So maybe it's something to do with that.
Hmm.
Quim origins.
Queef yeah,
that's where I really don't know.
But there needs to be a name for it,
which I think,
I thought Queef was widely accepted.
It is why they said it,
but it doesn't,
I think he's right in that it's not a logical deduction.
It doesn't make sense.
Why the Queef?
It should be called a p a puff.
A part.
Like when we were trying to come up with a fump.
Correct?
Correct.
Now you see it.
Oh poof.
Well,
let's look up where queef comes from.
Maybe wonder work queef comes from
Charles.
Given you the plug there.
It's a really
big debts.
Go See Christina do doing stand up.
Now we're talking standup
standups.
It might be hard for me to find the etymology.
Okay,
let me try it here at him.
Origin Queef
let's see what it says.
Yeah.
God.
Save the Queen.
Okay.
Uh,
no Spanish word for Queef.
Equip the sound of air escaping from the vagina during,
after intercourse is slang for vaginal flash and that we know that,
but we don't know.
MMM.
Interestingly,
in 1686,
although less frequently than previous definition,
quipping meant sexual intercourse especially had with or by a prostitute.
Okay.
Let me,
a Queef has changed and if I'm going hit shine from an,
an a queef relatively derogatory towards women.
Okay.
I don't fucking know
any,
no,
nothing,
nothing.
Nothing.
I mean,
it doesn't give us the etymology.
I,
I'd have to read it closely.
It sounds like it's been around for quite some time.
It's one of those words that you will fight,
like for instance,
scumbag.
Did you know that it's because the con condoms were called Gumbo.
You fill it with Scott
and then come just comes from scum.
Yeah,
we dropped the scumbag right.
And come back.
So it was probably just one of those,
you know,
16 hundreds.
It was like a funny fart.
Yeah.
Quigley.
I thought she was going to Queef
that much.
Wow.
Really Nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anything else?
Yes.
So uh,
we were talking a lot about twin dicks twins that are identical.
Okay.
Did
you find out some interesting sing
Dick News?
I did.
This comes from g James.
He writes,
hi.
Hey Hitler's.
I work with a set of paternal twins.
What are paternal twins?
Is that correct?
Or fraternal?
Yeah,
paternal.
Paternal twin.
Maybe that is a word.
I don't know.
The other day we were discussing podcasts and I brought up you're very
scientific question.
Do twins have identical penis?
Well,
it turns out in my cohort out in my coworkers have conducted an in depth
comparison.
In their case,
they do in fact have identical penises.
Oh,
it must be a fraternal was it's like an auto,
correct.
Probably.
I'm assuming they have identical fraternal dicks.
Yeah.
Wow.
Same size,
same shape,
same everything.
Right down to the curvature.
So even though they're not identical,
their penises are,
so yes,
this is fraternal twins.
I thought you would like to know this piece of information in your quest for
truth.
Keep it high and tight,
James.
Oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting.
Well,
it's funny because I'm Ryan sickle cell.
Sickler is a fraternal twin.
I and I mentioned this before,
he said they,
they've done comparisons and they have different dogs.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Well the mysteries of life,
everything,
the mysteries continue and mysteries continue.
And moving on to our blind series of questions.
We've been asking a lot of questions about the blind.
Can they wipe,
how do they know when they're done wiping a,
and this is an interesting one too.
Hey Mom,
I know this could seem like an obvious question,
but after hearing the superpowers of blind people knowing when they are done
wiping just by their senses,
I thought this could actually be the same way.
My question is,
Do Blind Men always pee sitting down?
To me,
this seems like an obvious yes because they can toilet odd.
I never thought of such a provocative question and we'll never know if they have
any extra spray to clean up,
but maybe their super powers are strong enough to handle this.
Again,
thanks for everything.
I would absolutely love glass in the podcast every week.
Well,
here's what I would say to that.
I mean at first you go,
of course,
what a brilliant thought.
But if you were blind and you know your space,
right,
you know your toilet,
you could still just be like,
oh,
here's the toilet.
And then you would know where it is.
You know how to aim and you also can hear your p hitting the water.
Well,
interesting.
I mean,
have you ever,
uh,
in the middle of the night,
gone to Pan,
you stand?
Oh,
of course.
Every single time.
Well then there you go.
When it's dark in there.
Yeah.
But I've,
I've done it in pitch black and I'm,
it's the little like in hotels,
you know,
and you're like,
oh fuck.
And then,
but you do,
you generally do it by like,
here it is.
Like you kind of get like a sense of the,
it's right here and then you go by the sound because the,
your p stream hits the water in the toilet and then all sudden you hear like
the,
uh,
the porcelain,
you're like,
oh,
I'm off to the,
and you kind of go back down to the water,
you know?
Fascinating.
I never knew this.
I never knew all this.
Do a urinal.
I mean,
I would assume that if the,
you know,
you know where it is,
you could aim for that.
I mean,
but it's an interesting question.
I think it's interesting.
We have a deaf question too.
Um,
here it is.
Uh,
how do deaf people wake up?
Oh my God.
How can we never have asked this before?
Thank you for answering life's important questions.
Like,
how do blind people and know when to stop wiping?
And two identical twins have the same size penis.
I have one that's been bothering me for some time out.
How'd you,
what deaf people wake up in the morning?
I'm talking about sound sleeping deaf people can't wake up to some weak flashing
light alarm or a tiny vibrating alarm.
You keeping your bed,
keep it high and tight.
Jason.
I go retarded.
I don't know.
That's a great question.
I assume that for the deaf they must sell a really strong,
really strong version of a flashing light and a vibration.
I know a lot of vibration vibration goes a long way with deaf people.
Yeah.
I'm going to go with smell a smell cal.
But how are you gonna have a smell alarm?
Um,
well we have those,
those MREs in our room.
Oh.
So like one of those goes off it smell machines.
You put something in there.
I mean,
you know how you wake up to somebody cooking breakfast downstairs?
I don't know why they can't make an alarm clock.
No,
you're right.
Smell.
I mean,
I remember in an,
uh,
in high school,
we played a deaf school once for a,
not for a regular season game,
but for a,
like a spring game.
And they had somebody hitting a drum on the sideline for the snap count.
Oh Wow.
Boom.
And then they knew like,
go on to go on three going on should they felt the vibrations vibrations.
We're sitting there like,
just,
you're so used to somebody going like blue 32.
Ha Ha.
Like nothing.
You just don't,
yeah,
we fucked them up.
We fucked those deaf kids up.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
No,
but I mean,
I thought it was interesting.
You know,
it is interesting.
And what'd you like think about?
You're like,
oh,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
They can't,
no one can do a snap count.
Regular one.
Mommy's,
since we use Mr to talk about males and miss and Mrs is talk about females.
What word do we use to refer to Zimmers?
Like ourselves?
Zach.
Huh?
Oh,
they are Zim.
So this is,
and this is,
oh,
is that,
how would,
if they are [inaudible] that's their pronouns then.
Right.
So here is the uh oh right are fun.
Right?
Cause you go like,
here's Mrs p,
right?
Fuck,
well this is crazy because does it,
does the non binary community completely as shoe the mister or missus
distinction because they're non binary,
right?
I'm nonconforming
gender.
You cool.
Right.
I would prefer that used my,
um,
okay,
what's your pronoun?
But I guess they're trying to say is like,
are you trying to to denote whether this person's a married Zamzar you know what
I'm saying?
Yeah.
So then that's the question.
Okay,
here's the question.
It's a good question.
So then how do you like,
here's Mr. So and so he's like,
let's say you're presenting someone right
who's none gender fuck conforming.
Would you say here is this is,
did you see that?
I'm like,
dammit,
that person said that,
uh,
that that old SNL sketch pat was anti-trans propaganda.
But you think,
oh,
that's fucking stupid.
Yeah.
I think it's silly to presume that 20 years in the past people had the
forethought of being transphobic.
Like it,
it just was like back then guys.
That's just how people were.
And it was a funny fucking sketch.
Everybody loved that character,
pat.
I don't,
I don't think anybody had any intention other than making people laugh back
then.
This is the person who,
uh,
who said it.
Jill Solloway is an American comedian,
playwright,
writer,
director Salaway identifies as nonbinary prefers a singular,
they pronoun won best director for Afternoon Delight,
also known.
They are also known for their work on six feet under and for writing.
Oh,
so this is,
they are the creator writer,
director of transparent.
Wait a minute though,
they were married to Bruce Gilbert and then separated.
Now how we,
I wish we could ask Joe what,
how she would prefer to be.
It's not she shit.
They,
how they would prefer.
Now here's a problem with a Va.
However,
as a pronoun is that it denotes a plural,
right?
It's not a singular person.
They are.
Yeah.
It's,
it's problematic.
I'm not sure that they is still the best pronoun for for this.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I'd stone in the English language and I'm not sure.
Oh man,
that's,
um,
but I thought that that the,
the story was absolutely absurd that,
that pat was not propaganda.
I don't think so.
That was a funny sketch and that sketch in my memory,
I mean,
yes,
it was a while ago was like universally celebrated as just a really funny,
like the concept of Pat,
if you never saw it,
was that you didn't know.
And so people were always like,
oh,
right.
They were actually,
everybody was trying to be respectful.
They weren't pronouns,
they don't want to Pat's feelings.
And so the whole thing was how they were tap dancing or,
and,
and kind of arousal to gender.
What gender are you?
And this is funny.
Then they would try to solve it and they'd think they got close.
Yeah.
And then they throw another curve ball.
You're like,
fuck.
Yeah.
And it was always really,
I thought was very cleverly written,
you know,
at the time.
Yeah.
I don't remember the exact details,
but I thought people loved pat and I thought of it as hateful or anything.
I don't,
I don't know.
What's Your Pronoun?
And I think,
I think,
I think they need to go to therapy and work out whatever.
I mean like if you're offended by something 20 years ago that SNL did,
like,
I think you got bigger emotional fucking issues.
I think they do have those.
Yeah.
You know what I was watching on Netflix?
A fucking police academy,
man.
Oh yeah.
Some people today,
you know what?
And I would think that too,
but it turns out all the underdogs of society or actually the heroes in that
movie.
If you think about it,
it's high tower.
Yeah.
It's officer Jones with attainment that avoids,
yeah.
That they always get the punch lines.
Yup.
And they're always goofing on the white commandant and the,
the white male characters punching up.
Yeah.
When you watch it again,
you go,
oh,
this isn't really that offensive.
Like I'm in.
There was one thing where Steve Gutenberg tells the spy,
the spy for the common dot.
He goes,
where are you guys partying this weekend?
oh yeah,
come to the blue oyster bar for that.
And it's like the gay dude.
But even so what happens is they end up dancing with the gay dudes in there and
it's cool.
Like it wasn't,
that was back then,
there were a lot of gay punch lines.
Yeah,
they'd be that.
I missed that.
Yeah,
that'd be like the big thing.
The big joke that somebody was gay.
Yeah.
So what should we go back and protest all those things?
Well,
I'm upset.
Propaganda.
Well,
and also look,
him control was in it and it was very sexist.
There are also parts where he's like,
what are your thighs like?
And she was like,
they're creamy.
And like,
what?
You know,
I'm deeply offended.
Of course.
How dare you,
how and feminist.
But it's just like the gays.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm very offended by Steve Gutenberg.
What he did,
you know,
30 years ago in a police academy movie.
I can't fuck with,
I can't,
I can't deal.
Well,
you know what the problem is?
It's not that people are offended.
It's that we're rewarding people for being offended over a horse.
Shit like this.
The fact that the media,
anyone's applauding this,
this book,
publishing that article,
it's crazy.
Right.
What are you planning?
What are you talking about?
This is rubbish.
That's not a story and I mean propaganda probably that would,
that would,
that would mean that that sketch was developed has a deeper meaning than just
the silliness of it.
It was,
it was meant to have the social ripples come on,
man of the non binary stuff
trying to bite my tongue.
Relax.
Right now we have 28 pounds and $900 a week.
Smith
can meet Joe.
Was He gone?
Foreign Dad's talk like that.
I feel more.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They curse a lot more on their way harsher.
I'm telling you I'll fucking push you out
guys related to me.
It's good
to
fucking push you out.
I'm telling you you do it again.
Really upset
or something.
I drive all the wide would be fucking shit to listen to.
Your fucking Smelly Fox.
Fucking freezing cold in here.
What'd your dad get this crazy?
No,
no,
no.
He's not bothered.
Who used to get like funny,
funny,
upset.
It was my uncle Dave.
He'd go,
when did you cut a fart?
When you cut a fart shit.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he's like,
Jesus Christ,
you stink.
And he would be like,
but we would laugh and laugh and laugh and he would be like fake up but like
kind of genuine upset.
It was funny.
It's always fun when someone gets upset from afar.
That's one life is worth living.
He would be upset.
My Dad really would be like,
he'll go,
whoa,
God stinks.
Wow.
Cause bad one.
That's the big reaction.
What did he roll down the windows?
At least you fart.
Whew.
Shit.
Yet like that.
Your Dad doesn't even get mad.
He's so sweet.
He's very low key.
My Dad was funny when I would fire it,
he'd be like,
fool.
Oh,
I started the way she's done it for am Buddha.
Buddha word buys Mac.
I think you are so stinky are so fucking gross.
Really?
And they roll down the windows just came in.
A buzz just came in.
Oh,
I didn't hear it.
Why don't we hear anything?
You don't hear it?
Nope.
Oh,
it must be your,
uh,
your line.
Am I lying?
Huh?
Your ear buds.
I Dunno when I cut that,
uh,
that channel to kind of,
how do I press pause and figure it out?
All right.
I better,
yeah,
I know.
I wanted to bring something up before he,
I wrote it down.
Yeah.
I had,
I took a fish oil pill like a week ago for our cholesterol and then I burped and
then an hour later and it smelled like salmon in my mouth.
Yeah,
it's gross.
That was terrible.
Yeah.
Really bad.
I a nasty.
Yeah.
I'm muted.
Does that go away?
Yeah.
You know,
I did.
I accidentally hit the PFL far,
but we're good.
Okay.
I've had those fish oil pills and it's like you,
it's like you just ate a fucking,
like a salmon buffet or something.
You can keep burping it up all day.
Nasties House.
Super Nasty as hell.
Yeah.
Mm.
So gross.
Get Out of your fucking big vigil.
That's enough.
Get Out.
I'm fucking
fucking pulling.
Oh,
it's got bad fucking bat ball game.
happy Mitchell.
And was nothing better than making your parents that happy or something stinky.
Of course Charlotte would get upset.
So upset.
She had very dramatic casting.
Ah,
ah.
She would and she would be like,
you're sick.
Like if she would do that whole thing,
you are
one fucking pulled over and you can run those juicy.
Good.
How are you?
Fuck and revolting.
Seriously five and you're fucking fun shit.
And he fights.
Oh my God.
Fuck.
Revamping or you fucking joke.
Oh,
what do you buy your baby?
Your daddy fuck off.
Oh my God.
That's called a protein bar.
I'm protein.
It's really funny.
That's called a protein bar.
Your mum stallion.
Yeah,
they are broke.
D Bar Code.
A protein.
Okay.
That's called a protein bar.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
Queens.
Lynn,
do you want to see a super excited guy?
I'm a guy who was super excited by these course.
He's really good.
Got It.
Bees and insects are capable of emotions that,
what would that imply?
I mean,
can you give us an idea?
I don't see your plans choose actually be absolutely on you.
These critters are amazing.
They get sad,
they get sad,
pessimistic at times.
These are not all seekers,
just like people know or not know,
and they can count at least to four or they can be trained to arrive at three,
four and five different times in a 24 hour cycle.
They vote these insects.
These little beings are extraordinary and there's central to our very existence
on planet earth.
Mm.
I have a pet peeve with people that are
animal experts sharing what animals feel and think as if they know,
because some reachers research was done when he goes there.
Pessimistic.
Some are thrill seekers.
Did you talk to them about it?
Did they tell you how they felt that day?
How do you know that what you are interpreting is sad is sad.
It's an,
it's a B.
What's the what?
What?
What is the behavior that you're like,
oh,
he's fucking sad.
Right,
and no way of knowing this guy.
She's always an adrenaline junkie.
This be over here.
Yeah,
I don't.
It's ridiculous.
They can't count to four either count a four at least.
There's no way.
Well,
other than produce.
Look at this crazy guy.
Crazy welfare bees.
How did these lower this a little bit,
this Kyra,
$577 billion for instance,
each year,
75% out of his fucking mind.
Super annoying.
At least 2.2 billion pounds of honey.
44 millions.
He holds a BS in La.
Yeah,
of course.
It's crazy pain and cancer.
Their medicines has warned that the disappearance of bees and
she looks like an MTV VJ rattling the cages as the glasses don't seem like
glasses.
No,
this guy's fucking,
this guy's it.
He's so crazy.
I bet you he knows how to eat a box though.
Do you think he has like super Coalinga skills?
God,
some nasty deadly poisons.
Neo Nica to noise poisons that at about a dozen.
Pardon?
Like,
uh,
those masturbation seminars.
Yeah.
[inaudible] in the circle and he's like,
you can stroke from the top and then you can,
one of the things I like to do is I switch hands.
So you go back and forth and you build up,
it'll build up that stamina and you just keep going and then you don't release.
Like he,
he's,
he's done truck guy.
This guy.
Yeah.
AndW as I said earlier,
it was 7.5 billion procreating humans without the bees.
We,
he's out of his mind.
I can't even watch it.
I know he's too much.
He's actually too much.
It's crazy.
Rob.
Rob,
rob,
do you think miss pat will like that guy?
Oh my God.
Which guy?
The Big Guy?
No,
the rub rub guy.
We should show her.
Rob.
Yeah.
I'm going to make a note of it.
We should show her the eye.
The Dad Bonar have a,
we can show her the bee guy and we could shore that.
The Canadian Trans Canada highway.
Yeah,
Dad.
He's great.
I'm just curious to see her thoughts.
What do you think she thinks we could ask her about the smell of ass kid?
Something's wrong with him.
Sure.
I bet she'll think something's wrong with him.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just burped and I burped up Broccoli.
I Made Broccoli for both of us today and you gave me a stellar review of my
cooking.
What did I tell you?
Well then tastes like shit.
That's what you said to me.
I said that the cause usually steamed broccoli.
It smells like farts and it tastes like shit and it's not,
but yours tasted good.
I don't know how you prepare it.
You didn't?
No.
You didn't say good at the time you go.
No,
it doesn't taste like shit.
And I was like,
wow,
what a stellar review.
I could have worded it differently,
but it doesn't taste like shit.
No,
I meant that.
It tastes good.
It doesn't taste like shit and then this is as bad as it used to.
All right,
let's take a quick break when you won't know.
We took a break.
We'll be back in mere milliseconds with the great miss pat joining us.
She's beautiful.
This is your
first door.
Alright,
we're rolling right now.
Just so you know.
Oh,
well
that's interesting because we were talking about
you got to give her some more volume.
I actually,
I think she's not even plugged up.
That'll help.
Oh yeah,
it will help.
Definitely give her some I hear now.
Did you hear that?
[inaudible] I promise you,
you're the,
you're the only person to lose that game.
No,
no,
no.
She came in,
she was within one of wanting the whole thing.
Juicy,
juicy,
juicy.
How did you come up with that?
Call me juicy all the fucking time.
Speaking of nicknames,
the new book comes out later this month is called rabbit and I was curious about
that.
And then I'm reading the book.
Uh,
it's your autobiography and you mentioned that you got the nickname rabbit
because I think it was,
it was your grandfather.
No,
my stepfather stepfather's
Curtis.
Came home one day.
Saw you like no
one on a,
on a carrot.
And he was like,
you eat a lot of those.
Your eyes going to be pretty.
That's the biggest fucking liar.
Who am I eat my eyes blue and we eat my eyes blue because I want it when I was a
key for some reason,
you know Jerry before Jerry curls.
Yeah.
So I really wanted to be white cause if you're in the book,
you really want,
you know,
you leave it to beaver.
Right?
So I wanted my hair because my mom wouldn't come my fucking hair and I figured
if I had that kind of hair,
this is before we'd,
yeah,
I could straighten it out and we would get a Jerry curl once a year and once Yo
get Jared Carol 30 90 days old,
that's it.
You fucking got an African Afro.
So,
uh,
so I wanted to,
I wanted to straighten my hair and I could,
I forgot to fuck what I was about to say.
Oh by having blue eyes and blue eyes and I want it to be white and you know,
cause leave it to beaver.
Had a perfect family,
eat them,
cares and your eyes be pretty.
Hey somebody who fucking cares.
My tick,
my,
my nose got strong from biting into them with my eyes and turn blue and my head
and straight.
Now it's like a,
it's an amazing,
amazing job that you did with the book.
Thank you.
It is like a roller coaster of there's parts that are just like heartbreaking
and like,
I mean you're like,
you know,
the struggle that you went through in your,
in your youth.
It is heartbreaking.
I mean,
you know that like reading it,
I mean there's,
there's parts that like you're kind of know you're,
you're happy for that.
You find your way through it and there's these moments of joy and things that
you could,
but like,
it's,
it's heartbreaking to read about,
you know,
the struggle you went through.
Do you know what's good about it?
I think it's a balance.
You know,
one minute you crying the next me like this,
this is crazy.
Then you laugh.
I don't want to like give away too much.
But you know that your grandfather's story,
I don't know.
Do you want to talk at all about them?
I mean it's just
bad ass.
I saw him on a regular every weekend,
choke the shit out of people and throw them out the door.
This isn't given up too much because this,
I mean,
so your,
your grandfather basically ran a bootleg house,
a bootleg house,
which was like,
you know,
if you want to place that doesn't shut down,
that serves drinks,
you can go to this house and your dad and your granddad has moonshine.
And like,
people could just kind of wild out and have a good night.
Right.
And then in Friday and Saturday was a club.
There's a club back then.
Everybody did the album.
So everything,
the music helped my,
you know,
my mom was a Dj to keys,
get in the flow and dance.
I fucking hated it because you were literally,
he would never put you out unless you act like a fool and he don't look Jay.
Other than that,
you could get drunk.
You didn't,
you didn't have to dry.
Just sleepover.
You wake up,
you next it.
Who the fuck are you pourable the work,
you know,
there's,
there's different things that you read that make you feel and think of different
ways.
But one of the things was the idea of being a kid and having strangers asleep in
the house that seemed like that would suck.
Right?
Like today it was suck,
but you know,
that was my environment.
You know,
I would never have it happen to me.
But when that's your environment,
that's all,
you know,
like going some way.
He's like,
what the fuck them people ain't got no shoes when they don't know shit about
shoes.
So you wake up next to some drunk mother fucker where he,
you won't wake up and you roll over it.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
it was,
it was the norm,
the norm until I got out of that environment.
So it wasn't scary because nine times out of 10 you knew the drunks.
They came every week.
You know,
it's the truth.
What you're saying.
Sorry,
I don't,
I mean,
yeah,
when you grow up in something that's so bananas,
which are Your Life Story is so bananas,
you don't know at the time,
then it's nutty until you grow up and you start raising your own children,
I'm assuming.
And I'm like,
what the fuck was that about?
You know,
the biggest shock to me when I,
uh,
and I'm moving past it,
a little bootleg house,
we could come back.
But when we grew up,
we were so poor and we ate chicken back.
You know,
off the back is the little ass.
They're like a chicken nugget.
So we ate that shit every week,
the chicken.
So when I grew up in,
I was like,
y'all don't eat chicken and nobody ate chicken and that was Paul people,
chicken nuggets.
That was a shocker to me.
Right,
because chicken nas was good until you realize it was a search thing is chicken
and I threatened my keys,
I'll tell is like Ashley Fry up you a batch of chicken.
There's,
there's a sale chicken as an Atlanta by the pound.
Really?
So that was a shocker to me that the crap we ate and that was a treat
that was bought at a chicken.
You were supposed to eat it.
My mom used to fry up cow brains all the time and give it to me.
That's a Hungarian thing.
And I was like,
what the fuck is this?
And she told me,
I was like,
never again.
But that was,
that was cheap I guess.
Cal Brands.
Yeah,
I mean,
and then they make it taste so good.
Like chitlins I won't eat,
I won't eat nothing that remind me of being poor.
I worked too hard to get away from that crowd.
Yeah.
I can't eat no spam and I can't eat no cheese,
no cheap brand.
My husband's like,
you are the most bougie person I know.
I go to Mcdonald's,
say make my food hot.
He's like,
Pat,
this is Mcdonald's.
I don't care.
But I mean I worked too hard.
I cannot eat.
I go down the aisle and I see a certain type of food.
It makes me angry.
Spans make me angry.
Nasty though.
Well not back in the day cause we didn't have bacon.
So you fry that up with some grits.
Awesome.
Fat Back.
That was a good meal.
But ketchup sandwiches.
The ketchup sandwiches.
Yeah.
And it was never named brand kitchen was watery stuff and went and soggy the
bread or sugar sandwich.
Manet Sandwich.
Yeah.
My kids don't know anything about that.
Do you actually
eat chick filet?
All of life.
There's so many good things in the book,
but I love the honesty with which you talk about everyone in the family.
A lot of people wouldn't be honest about it,
Tom.
It was hard because when you be in a,
you know,
it wasn't a t.
I became an adult that I realized it's stuff that I really went through,
the abuse that I went through.
And one thing I learned from this book when you been on a lot of people being
abused,
want to protect their abuser and that was the in the right ahead.
And tell me your p two people out.
Celt protect.
It was her father,
my first kid's father and I protected my mom and it's like,
don't write them like that.
He was,
and she was like,
pat is to truth.
I said,
but I don't want people to think of my mom and like,
oh,
I don't want them to think,
because she was saying he's a pedophile and I was like,
he's not a pedophile.
He was my boyfriend.
She was like,
oh,
excuse me,
you was 12 and he was 21 or you was your,
you gave birth at 14 and I think he was 22 or something like that.
It was an eight year difference.
He,
I know.
All I know is I was 14 she was like,
that's a pedophile.
So Ah,
that was my baby daddy.
She was like,
no pet,
they didn't protect you.
So that was really hard for me to [inaudible] to,
cause I kept putting up walls.
I mean obviously it made it in,
but like so was it her that convinced you?
Yes,
she had to sit me down and made me realize that these people did not protect me.
We cry so much with this book.
Really.
We cried.
That was time.
I would tell her stuff and I could just hear break up in a voice,
you know,
I gotta call you back.
And then she was like,
you know,
cause I'm full,
I'm 15 with two babies by a married man.
And she was like,
what the hell?
The sea.
And you know what's crazy?
He signed the birth certificates and no,
do you need no damn id to sign the birth certificate?
Even in 1986 in 1987 you need a birth certificate.
And I mean,
I'm not a burst.
If you needed an ID,
he walked in as a grown man and sign a kid who just had a kid birth certificate
and nobody questioned it.
So when she started bringing all this stuff to my attention,
because I lived it,
I really never paid it.
It made me so angry.
I was like,
this shit.
They just,
they didn't give a crap about me.
They literally did not give a crap about me and that stuff kind of,
it really,
Emma,
it really bothered me because I never thought about it because when I had her,
I'm 14 years old,
driving out in the eighth grade.
I don't want it to do with survive.
All I wanted to do was keep us from being molested,
keep her from dropping,
not survive.
So I went to selling dope.
I mean,
I can admit with $40 but I had to steal it because when I tried to get a job and
I was 15 nobody would give me a job and I would literally tucked him on an
interview one day and say,
this is my job.
This is my work permit.
Ashland Nikea meet them.
But then it was like,
y'all ass idea,
you supposed to be in school,
but you know that that was the hard part for me.
It was just all about surviving was making the transition into selling dope.
Was it difficult at all or no,
they did it.
They daddy was selling drugs first.
So you know,
he got a divorce because I had the second baby.
So he went on to the next girl,
like he always did.
And so he started selling drugs,
but he was still paying my rent and you know,
I was so young and dumb as long as I was number one.
The rest of the holes didn't matter what,
he never lived with me and they live with somebody else,
but I always told me I was number one.
So he started selling drugs.
He was paying my bills.
So I kinda agreed to the range me,
okay,
you know what you needed to,
I sort of keep your baby alive and or feed them.
So,
and I mean,
I'm too young to get a job,
but he got locked up and that's when I was like,
I really had to survive.
And at that time I was only 16 when he went to jail for selling drugs.
At first I went to the projects because that's why all the jokes were so far
from where you were though.
No,
I wasn't that far.
My girlfriend had a friend.
My girlfriend had a boyfriend who was a drug dealer and we went over there and I
will try to sell.
It was just too many people.
There's too much competition,
so I ended up back in my own neighborhood,
which was up on a corner.
I posted up at a friend house.
I went over to some old friend's house that I grew up and got the whole family
to sell drills.
Even their Christian Mama,
I'll never forget the day she got burned.
He got busted by the police.
They took a fake leg off and found out a dope.
The police put handcuffs on her ass home.
I love 'em.
I love you know the stories about you guys,
your mom discovering the church too.
Oh yeah.
I tell you,
I was so naive.
I had no idea that she was only supposed to be baptized once until no lie.
About five years ago,
I was on the phone with my friend and we was talking about baptism and um,
I was like,
she said,
I said,
yeah,
well we got baptized.
I got baptized like 20 sometimes I think it's 25
she said,
wait a minute.
I was like,
well,
she's like,
who the Hell Baptize you 25 times?
How many times you've been baptized?
She was like,
once I said,
who the hell I baptize you was going to hae?
So she said what?
What happened?
And then I remember I was like,
oh my gosh,
she was running a scheme because we would just show up at different churches and
you like,
keep your fuck,
keep your fucking mouth shut.
Don't ask no questions,
just get in this water.
I get this check and we get the fuck up Outta here,
man.
She went to literally open the phone book and hit different churches,
give them that Sas.
But that's back when churches cared about you too.
And when she discovered the White Churches,
oh,
she lost her damn mind.
Yeah.
You know,
back in the 80s you guilty white people want to make sure that day that they get
into heaven.
Let me help this poll.
Black family,
you know,
you go to a black child,
a like one item at the Pantry,
Mitch,
one item.
Oh the whole patches get what you want.
God.
So he called my Mama with three checks and I bet her wallet already.
God is good all the time.
They shut the fuck up dude.
Throwing shit now.
We were sure.
Where does she,
I hated it.
I'm like,
Mama,
how long we got to do must've
been like salvation though.
It was,
he helped her with the rent.
It helped with me.
No,
it's a fool's game.
Yes.
I mean we hit those different churches.
That's how we ate.
Yeah.
And we would drive,
you know,
out,
cause you know,
you had to join a church back then to,
you know,
to get baptized and get help.
So I,
we had a lot of members,
Sheila pay no time
is there was like,
one of the things too is like,
you know,
writing is good writing and good storytelling when you go,
I don't know the experience,
but you still feel it when you talk about how,
you know when you were a kid and you're watching commercials for food and like
you could only dream about it,
you know,
I didn't have that experience but I could like step into what you were feeling.
Yeah.
I can step into your world and be like,
oh,
he's like,
you're so poor that you don't have access to even go to Mcdowell.
Your mom's like,
black people don't eat McDonald's.
No,
she's a Niggas don't leave me.
I said it there.
They
tech is a MAG Nigga.
Nigga down a dash 10 when I eat a burger and they never ate a burger.
You're so right.
It was his dad dance as well.
I really thought black people didn't eat McDonald's whenever she didn't want to
buy shit.
A Nigga don't do that.
Don't do that.
Don't do to help you like pink too.
Like,
okay,
we don't do that.
That's a crazy
Cigna grow up with,
which is just like culturally we don't do that.
So where there are lots of things that by the time you became an adult that you
kinda had to unlearn all that,
right?
Yeah.
When I became a drug dealer,
I went straight to Mcdonald's.
First
Burger King
was,
he never said she couldn't afford it.
She just said,
we didn't do it.
We didn't do it,
which is different things then I can't afford it.
You hear that as a kid and like your parents telling you,
you're like,
oh,
okay.
That's the way reality is.
Yeah.
That you said,
yeah,
that's like,
oh,
I didn't know that.
Okay.
That's what we're supposed to know.
What I think is really wonderful about your book,
and I think why people are going to be drawn to it.
It's because the white people,
why people buy,
why people are like,
why people are going to enjoy people blaring.
Um,
is that you always liked to read other people's fucked up shit first of all
because then you can go,
oh my God,
at least my shit wasn't that fucked up.
But also to go,
hey other people,
shit is fucked up.
Yes.
And the fact of it is more people have fucked up lives then have good lives.
Uh,
cause I do another podcast called that's deep bro,
where I talk about my life and,
and people writing in or like,
oh Mike,
I didn't know anyone else had the same shit that you had growing up.
And that's why the stuff like this is so valuable.
Not only is it funny,
but they get to know somebody.
You who has transcended this past and look at you now.
Like you have a great family,
you're successful,
you're a great comedian.
Like to see you on the other side of it I think is really cool too.
Yes.
And that's all I wanted people to realize.
No matter what isn't,
it's not about how you start,
it's about how you finish.
Yup.
Mean,
you know,
I don't think all white people had an easy life.
Just like all black people in all Chinese an ever.
There's,
there's,
I think there's a struggle in every,
in every nationality.
That's what I learned.
Like I thought only black teenagers got pregnant cause that's all I saw.
I didn't see why people use the case worker,
the fucking,
the police officer who dropped off food buy a house because he knew my mom was
an alcoholic.
That's the only white people I saw.
So I thought when I got pregnant in hood,
only black kids get pregnant.
That makes sense.
Then when I started doing comedy,
because you know,
I changed when I changed my life,
I share all of this shit off.
I don't know shit about to get on.
I don't know how,
I don't know.
No new dance and new music and nothing,
nothing.
That's what she remembered.
The dances,
what?
I cut it all off and when I,
when I started doing comedy,
people from all walks of life would come up to me.
It was like,
oh Ms Pat,
I went through the same thing I never get,
I saw this white lady and her husband had on an ascot.
He anytime y'all ass guy,
he's supposed to have money and just assume that person.
And she whispered in my ear and she said,
I had my baby at 15 and the bitch had on a ring beginning of my fucking eyeball.
And I was like,
are you for real?
She's like,
yes,
I had my baby at 15 thank you for telling your story.
And that made me realize we all go through the same shit.
It's,
some people are just scared.
I was in Atlanta,
New Year's and this black girl said I had my baby at 15 to,
she said,
but I'm a shame.
How can you talk about it?
I said,
cause bitch,
I don't care.
I don't care what nobody think of me.
She was like,
you brain cause I could never,
she said,
I don't even tell my child my age.
That's how I don't give a fuck with my kids.
Think about me.
They don't feed me.
They grown.
Fuck them.
I can't five Texas for my kids.
I don't give a fuck about me.
I mean,
I kept him from getting pregnant.
Yeah.
I was like,
Wah,
Wah pregnant,
getting pregnant.
I think I beat her gay.
I was like,
stay away from this.
Stay away from debt.
I was like,
God damn.
That's what I'm saying.
Get a little bit of deep,
you know.
Uh,
she say she was [inaudible] she was gay about fourth grade.
Right?
Ashley?
She say fourth grade,
but she saw a lot too.
So I don't know if it was a bad relationship between me and her daddy when she
saw a man just constantly beating on a woman
actually goes,
no.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm gay.
Actually sitting behind us on the couch for those of us who are watching on
youtube.
Yeah.
So you know what the strange thing when she came I gay,
you know,
I had already been to jail,
did time and I really didn't like gay women.
Gay Men's is okay.
But I did not like get nobody raped me or anything.
I just didn't like gay women.
And so I say what you don't like,
God put it in your life.
And when she came she ran off and you know,
quit school and we,
we,
we didn't have a relationship.
And then one day I finally found after two or three years not talking to her,
I was like,
what's your problem?
Are you gay?
And she said,
well come on home bit
you,
it's a lot of pussy here in Atlanta.
We've been friends ever since.
And then she tried to help me help all get home.
No,
I'm not hooking it up.
Okay.
I'm not looking at it though.
That's strictly on her.
When I was you get to eat,
there's old work
we've been talking about.
We wanted to show you,
first of all,
this is a which one first you want to do the,
yeah.
So it's fine.
Your opinion on something.
This man is teaching guys who,
uh,
who want more control over their orgasms,
how to sharpen their knife.
They penises.
So the women practice on the egg.
What did the men do?
Okay,
the man,
the first thing,
oh,
hail housing.
They would call sharpening their nice,
and this is what he says you have to do.
So the whole case,
you'd get an oil,
we caught the baby oil oil and you put it in and now you put the peanuts to warm
up in the cold winter.
You warm them up,
you get a hot power and you'll make it a one and you put here,
make sure all the blood flow.
Now you get the penis out,
you pull the skin.
A lot of people,
they never succumb fences.
So they had the skin.
So you pull the skin and you get up and he'll run like this.
The rap rap,
rap,
especially on the Klan Penis rubbed them the gland.
Okay.
You met them strong and not sensitive.
Now he's saying that he wants like an order to build up that control.
You need to Rub your Dick 350 times 50
he got me when he's,
they pulled the skin bag.
Who pulled us came back.
That's your grandpa penis?
Yeah.
Right side.
Left side.
Front foot.
With the time,
Dow.
Okay.
How often am I doing this?
Do you have to do every day until you can control every day.
So this guy's obviously shitting his pants.
He's telling him,
this guy is saying that he jerks off basically 350 strokes a day every day.
Well,
he,
the control is keep yourself from nothing.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
I'm going to use the wrong word.
Calming.
Yeah.
After a week of doing that shit,
you shouldn't be able to call him.
You should be.
So you put,
you're rubbing it to the right,
rubbing it to the level upstairs.
Johnny's
got an invisible penis,
Neda rubbing away.
It's a lot of rubbish.
I've got a set of balls,
that's all.
Maybe that's why he can rub,
rub so much.
He's so smart.
Putting the knife.
Okay.
All right.
Have you done traveling the night?
There's the number one.
Number two,
you have to learn how to contracting the prostate gland because this guy is also
saying that when you have as a man,
when you feel the orgasm coming,
stop and feel it internally,
but don't release it.
It's a lot to ask.
I don't know nothing about that.
Yeah,
I have a penis.
So is that like stopping a piece in Mc ash?
It kind of thing.
So people cannot separate and they,
they don't know at the squeeze on Anna's,
that's it don't work.
So when we can track the faucet,
because male g spot is in process,
right?
So when you contract the prostate gland in the front and you feel energy
activate here,
so as you contract and you feel here accurate,
not when many circulation,
the pressure of the declaration.
If I'm the prospect and contracting,
okay,
so I'm exercising,
I see assignment.
Okay.
And Far people have project land stolen or problem.
This one who solved their problem.
Okay.
Just that contraction 300 times you need to do 300 that old Chinese man problem
is right.
He don't eat too much of that fucking fake rice.
And John,
he's crazy.
He's nuts.
He's crazy.
I just think he's a pervert.
And who likes to Jack His dick a lot.
And then he's like,
here's my method.
Yeah,
he's tried to make you more money,
but he's just like a dude.
It likes to jerk off a lot and now he's turning it into like a thing.
When I'm a guru,
until you feel and hit listen to this area,
I'm going to throw it out.
The guy,
some without ejaculation.
What?
Watch.
So you feel so you see when you do,
when?
When you get it,
it's very quick to two times can.
No
piece of the cheeks.
He pees in the cheek.
He is paying in vagina.
They need to rest is says,
isn't this?
He thinks he's super miss parent.
I hate him.
What would you make love to him?
No Chinese.
First of all I did.
I'm assigned my race,
but I don't go all the way over there.
What's your race spectrum?
Does black just black so far?
You would never go.
Wait.
Oh
I don't.
Yeah,
I guess what
White Mans are not into Dick.
Black.
Blue.
They don't even like fat.
That's not true.
There's black guys.
The black guys love,
I'm sorry.
White,
white,
white men is they,
they,
that's why you usually see fact girls were white meat.
So,
I mean,
I've never had a white man.
Did he throw me really ever.
Right.
That's hard to believe.
Do since these pocket,
they think I'm cute.
I want to fuck me.
You know,
back in the day,
no.
Oh,
not about.
Okay.
But the Rab Rab Guy,
what if I were to offer you $100,000 cash to do what?
To have sex with him to what?
You sleep with the rope rope Gafa a hundred thousand dollars.
No,
I don't.
It will be easy because he really got no peanuts.
I don't be sticking right in my navel cause he's kind of deep and would think he
getting it.
So I take your hundred thousand dollars upon.
Yeah.
So can I fix her mic?
It's killing me.
Yeah.
What's really quick?
Just a v the visual part on Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You want to see her?
Beautiful.
Okay.
That was a quick grab.
So you would never date a Chinese guy.
Huh?
That's not going to happen.
There's very small.
So what I'm gonna do with them using for a Tampon?
No,
I don't think so.
I mean,
I don't think the old beyond his own.
I probably could do a white man first,
but I've never seen a Chinese guy that,
you know,
I thought was a track that I'm quite sure they,
I don't think I'm attractive either.
No,
that's honest.
Let me think about days we always in and out.
They're still buying hair in one.
Never hit on me.
We always in a shit,
I'm black hair.
Prato cause I've never seen one.
Was it like that?
Was it a Asian owned?
Uh,
in Atlanta?
Everywhere.
It's always,
they don't tell you what to get there hugging hair from.
They would not tell you.
Oh my God,
really?
They will not sell out if you're not Asian,
you can't buy hair.
I was fascinated by that.
Uh,
Chris Rock documentary.
Yeah.
Good hair.
That was really,
really insightful.
I had no idea.
Black woman,
we spend a lot of money on their hair.
It was crazy.
I got about 500 on this file.
Yeah.
Cause the front is on lace.
Oh,
what does it call Ashley Lace?
Frontal.
So it cost like one 51 75 something like that.
And it thins out quick.
So about three hairdos you need another one in the back.
Um,
it was Bondo,
so spent about 400,
three,
400 barrier.
It's just thousands and thousands of dollars.
It could be you get the good hair that last you a whole year,
so all you got to do is replace the front.
But if I'm doing TV as on my whole novels,
five,
$600.
Yeah.
But it hurts.
And to have the,
cause you have to braid the hair under,
correct.
Yeah.
That's under,
that does not hurt or you get used to the pain.
Well,
um,
I'm very,
I used to be very telling the heated,
but I've done it so much that it doesn't hurt as much anymore.
Yeah.
And is it keeps the damage off your real,
how to,
you know,
like we can't,
we can't straighten out hair like that every day.
Yeah.
We can't curl our hair.
Like the sheet I do today is,
hey,
you can't do it.
That's so funny.
That word.
A tender headed because I feel like I would be like that.
You know,
like I have sensitive scalp.
Okay.
You know what I have?
They have a lace front of me is now you seen that?
Are you saying that you get it?
I should try it.
No.
Have you seen it as we showed him the picture is fucking wow for dudes.
Why m black means it is the most craziest shit you could be having sex in your
hands slip off and your man Hell slip too.
But it looks so real now.
I'm telling you the barbers are doing it.
You got men's doing me and lay fries should do at Tom.
At least look into it.
Yeah,
I'll look.
I Nate and once they put it on you,
they give you a haircut with it.
So everybody's faking Atlanta.
Yeah.
You can't even fucking tell who got the fake hair to man or the woman.
Wow.
You're talking about speaking of Atlanta?
Uh,
Tyler Perry.
Yeah.
Gay or straight.
Oh No,
stop it.
He got a baby.
Stop it.
No,
he do have a baby.
Are you doing at the Tyler?
Why are you going to do that?
Because I feel like it's a big,
it's like a secret,
not secret.
Monique just came out with audit and miss.
Somebody was gay.
I don't know.
Monique did you to see out a big thing.
You don't own the Internet shit.
Here is Tom.
They're putting a weave on him.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit is deep.
Wow.
This guy looks really good.
Oh Wow.
That looks,
Huh?
But it's also like in the,
you know how when videos are shot,
you're like,
oh,
this looks good on the video.
I don't know.
No,
I've seen men's with it.
Really?
Yeah,
it is the bomb.
All right.
Oh,
there you go.
You don't get long hair like that guy.
I'm going to come.
No,
no,
he's going to cut it.
They're going to cut it into a haircut.
Oh,
okay.
so they put it in and then now they'll do it.
Okay.
And how long would it stay like his hair like this?
You got to keep getting it redone
once a week.
Once a week.
Oh,
it's glued down.
Yeah,
it's a lot of upkeep.
It's a lot of,
I could see like meeting someone,
you start dating and then you're like,
just keep your secret and then all of a sudden it's like year and a half later
and y'all go swimming and you're fucking happy.
Fall off.
Um,
I haven't been going to AA meetings every Wednesday getting my hair.
Well,
what about somebody would have fake ass.
So you know,
she got a compressor.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
You did it.
And he was white.
He was white.
He man,
we kicked him out.
Yeah,
he was.
He's cute.
I'm telling you.
That's the new shit.
Now when you sat down Ms Bower,
I think we're just right before we started rolling.
You said that I was regular white and,
and let's start.
Let's talk about that.
What are the levels of what?
Yeah,
tell us about why people is,
is like,
you guys are regular white.
Okay.
I don't think other race of people scare you.
Right.
Then you got that off,
then you got that uh,
uh,
unconnected white.
Just only see white people.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
So when they see other people,
they start sweating and shit.
I start thinking about everything they see on the TV band and a movie thinking
is motherfuckers act a who home run up on him and do the shit they scene in the
movie.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then you got to white.
That's the rear rear rich people.
One of the execs I said,
hey,
your son has a cute will you get them from,
she's asking you a link.
So I learned is don't ask race people where the fuck they get the shits though.
$650.
That's more than two of my car note was put together.
That's a bit tired at the wall.
I was insulted.
I was like
a pole personal link for some sound does dumb shit was automatically became ugly
as fuck to me if she,
um,
I think we're in that,
in that situation,
if somebody goes like,
that's just nice that you got and you know how much it costs,
you should be like,
yeah,
I forget where I got like in hood,
but they don't want you to go get it.
Right.
Right,
right.
You know,
they want to be the shot of him.
I'll fucking hood.
That's right.
If you know,
he's like,
oh,
it was about 600 and you turned me out.
Oh,
okay.
What did they good for?
You don't see me know Lincoln,
you know,
you got to open up a link.
Can you talk about what you're doing as far as I thought I put pilot.
Well I was on a podcast,
Allah,
you guys together and uh,
a guy from imagine heard me,
he heard me out for where the book came from,
all of you guys.
And he heard me on a mark Marin and some other ones.
He hurt.
And um,
he took me over to where I hooked up with Lee Daniels because Lee has a deal
with Fox with 20th
or for those who don't.
So Empire,
uh,
the Butler and pressures.
And so we took it lead Daniel Imagine in Maine in 20th,
took it to Fox and they bought a put pilot saying that they would shoot the
pilot and if they like it,
they'll pick it up from series.
And it is the hardest shit I have ever done in my life.
What do you mean when you say hardest?
What is it?
What do you mean by a lot of back and forth?
That I'm not used to,
you know what I'm saying?
Start over,
start over.
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with you people?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the thing.
It's just,
you know,
I don't like this.
Why you don't like this?
Then you got to explain stuff and they still don't get it.
And then,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not a TV exec.
I just know you say you want to do a show about me is pat.
All I know is Miss Pat.
I don't know this other shit.
You talking about the show then followed?
Like is it you right now?
Is it me now?
I mean moving into a,
uh,
me leaving Atlanta,
moving into,
I'm a all white conservative neighborhood.
Gotcha.
You know,
opinionated and you know,
do what I do in my real life.
Kids grow up my,
if you do that,
that show will be shot out here,
I assume,
right?
Yeah.
It'd be shot here.
And Are you guys about to start shooting?
Are we well,
I had a writer,
it didn't work out,
so we just got the writer who did everybody.
Hey Chris.
So we have a meeting tomorrow.
Hopefully they'd tell us,
go write the pilot stage.
We've been trying to get back to.
So once we do that hopefully was shooting out out.
It's exciting work to me.
You know what?
I come from a world,
well this is how I taught myself.
Don't believe half the shit you hear half the shit you see and none of this shit
you here,
right?
Yeah.
So it ain't real to me until I put it in my hand.
This book ain't real.
It's real now.
But people that all you got a book,
Bitch,
I don't know.
They could tell them.
The first time I wrote,
we wrote the book,
they say put it in the trashcan and started all that shit blew my mind.
I was like,
bitch,
I need that money.
I started a layaway.
Uhh,
I've already spent the money,
but I can't get the money.
So that shocked the hell out of me.
You know,
wait,
you wrote it once and they said throw it away.
I started out,
I was like,
it was a great decision,
but at the time I couldn't understand because I got so mad.
Oh my God,
I got so mad.
I was like,
I wasted a year of my life.
And you're gonna tell me to start over.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I Wa I was ready.
I was fired.
Or they had to calm me down.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause I'm running well from you.
Like the publisher that says that it was the editor.
They go,
this is just not working.
Well,
she says,
not working.
It's too dark.
We had to take out some things where you're writing some things,
but I tell you,
once I calmed down and we finished this book,
that was the best fucking ideal.
Really.
At the time you added concede,
you know,
I couldn't see what she was talking about,
but now it made the book,
her idea really made the book better.
The further the pages just turn on it now.
It just,
yeah,
it was too dark.
It was a little too dark.
Yeah.
We didn't want the audience to put the book down and go fill.
Sorry for this little black girl standing together.
I want you to take these horrible stories and laugh at him the way we wrote
them.
Yeah.
I want you to say,
okay.
All right.
All right,
Ms. Pay you fucking up again.
Yeah,
I'm cheering for,
you know,
you laugh and then you cry.
I want all type of emotions and that's what this book got now.
Yeah.
At first you probably would have got through the first 30 pages and been crying
like I'm over Gil.
Oh,
you're white guilt.
I'm so over it.
So we wrote out all the white guilt and that's a great,
yeah,
I sure hope so.
God Dang.
So,
you know,
it made it a better book.
But you know,
the whole TV thing is,
is is,
is the hardest thing I ever done.
It really is.
Yes.
Because I mean,
I,
I pretty much raised myself so I don't take no for an ounce of it.
Right.
Because I knew how to get out there and hustle and do what I need to do.
But then you got these other people who's calling shots in your life.
Desta Desta thing for me,
that's the thing I don't like.
I don't like you telling me what to do.
Sure.
Eh,
you know,
it's their money.
They're going to tell you what to do,
that you're going to stay at the hotel.
They say you're going to do this,
you're going to do that.
And then it,
they're wonderful me.
They treat me,
they treat me really fucking good.
I feel guilty cause we ain't got to show and I feel like I'm taking their money.
Right,
right,
right.
But you know,
the whole thing is that right now I can't call the shots.
You know that they listen to my opinion.
Yeah.
But ultimately their decision make a decision.
They make making this show.
So that's the thing that really gets me.
I understand that.
Yeah.
But it sounds like a whole like corporate culture to that.
As a comic,
especially,
you know,
we bypass a lot of that corporate bullshit because we perform live for a living
and you don't have to deal with it.
So when you have to deal with it creatively,
it's so fucking frustrating.
All the,
you know,
circle back,
put a pin in it.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
and I first read it spicing twins 14 when I was having sex with my girlfriend
and her sister,
she had this really strong smell of Os out pretty enjoyable and arousing.
It kind of smelled like this rich odor of body sweats combined with the smell of
shit basically.
What are you thinking of?
I would
tell you did,
it was,
we had a,
my granddad had a customer,
he,
he's a childhood friend of my Mama.
He grew up,
he grew up,
his name was Tom Aaliyah.
Never forget it.
You know,
down south we got them thick acids.
Yeah.
So he would cook,
he'd be like back back here or big jaws.
I they called my granddad
give me a cup of ice.
Said you woke up.
Okay.
No,
they will pick out him so bad cause he couldn't say eyes.
Right.
You always ask for a couple of days.
Yeah.
This conversation about,
you know,
dudes are obviously bigger pigs,
like men in general.
Are you know,
animals.
So this guy is talking about how he gets aroused by smells like funky smells on
women.
You think women ever have that same thing?
Christina Says No.
I mean it'd be a,
you have to be a real fucking savage woman.
The average woman's like not wired this way,
I would say.
What do you think Ashley?
Yeah,
Lasker.
Oh,
you aroused by funky smell vaginas?
No.
What about,
what about a real stinky ass?
Yeah.
See,
look like you like sticky as ash.
Well,
that's what this guy just said.
Just so you know.
We're not just throwing that at you.
This guy said that he likes a stinky ass.
You know?
I know it sounds disgusting,
but it smelled really nice to me.
I really liked the smell.
Is that weird?
We stopped because the scheme,
they just mail me on the wrong day.
Yes.
Yeah.
That stuff,
right?
Oh yeah.
He just hates me right now.
He's smelling that on that all high school.
Vagina.
Yeah.
He's male.
A vagina.
And I had a couple of baby down.
She didn't only seven peed on the pen and locker.
I guarantee changing
even gets aroused by other like this.
Check out this smell.
Remember that Uranian Gold I met last year in Japan,
the one I asked if she wanted to have sex with me and she said No.
Well,
one of the main reasons why I felt so attracted to her,
it wasn't because I thought she was pretty or cute.
It was because she had this amazing smell of armpits.
Every time she sat next to me and my room,
I could smell this strong,
rich,
bitter smell of arm pit.
And it was really arousing.
He like [inaudible].
Yeah.
And Stinky ass holes.
He likes our faith and assholes.
It's,
yeah.
He was in Japan and the,
I guess an Iranian girl was there.
Oh Wow.
He need to go get a couple of them.
All was people named has ramped up.
Oh yeah.
Well,
uh,
you know,
Middle Eastern.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I wonder what he'd like it out the day.
Yeah.
He may be carrying a trip.
Maybe should go to Saudi Arabia.
They were black too.
A lot of them in the middle of summer.
So she's,
they're assholes.
Have to be very smelly,
sweaty,
stinky ass hole.
I want to do the women have on close up on it here.
They do so cause I yes they do.
And a lot of them are wearing like Chanel and Dior and they're very wealthy.
Like some of these uh,
Saudi ladies.
But then they have to cover it out in public,
but then they know amongst themselves the whole culture of like what you got on
under there,
bitch.
And then they,
yeah,
now
I got to shop.
I love the shop to play for you.
Do you think this is a white woman or a black woman?
Okay.
Oh,
this one's good.
Yeah.
Why didn't you please hear Charlie honey?
Oh my God.
Get your passenger
gets you past that was a fucking white woman.
Fucking hillbilly.
Oh,
well first of all,
I know she,
she's white.
Yeah,
you were no black person.
They'll say get to pass.
And they be like,
Yo,
that Nigga,
you know.
Right.
We'll be all up in their head.
That was black bird.
That was a fucking passenger.
You know,
we should ask Ms Pat.
Remember that girl we had last week who was dropping n bombs left and right.
Oh yeah.
We had this debate.
Do we,
do we have her on?
Yes.
Watch this video and I dunno,
let's start there.
Is there ever a time when it's okay for a white person to drop the n bomb?
Like if let's say they hang out with this person,
get real comfortable,
like real comfortable.
You just hear you watch,
oh,
stop.
She looked,
she looked though has shown a phone.
She started recording,
you said,
right?
Yeah.
But have you seen this already?
Yeah,
she was dating a black guy,
so yeah.
That's why she feels she's right.
That's the whole thing.
So I actually said,
if you can hear her,
that she's dating a black guy.
This is the white lady we played last week who's driving in bumps and Ashley
says she's dating a black guy.
So she feels like she can write,
right?
Yeah.
Play it.
I haven't seen it.
Oh right.
Hmm.
That's the bat.
Malia come in and my little pause for my Nigga.
Guess what?
Boom.
At the end of the day,
I'm still going to go home to my Nigga,
fuck him and get my pussy ate while you hose.
Just saying,
okay.
Oh,
I ain't gonna beat the Shit.
I didn't.
How was she getting it down?
This is by the way,
at the beginning of it dropped like a hundred
Oh,
you and your dog was sad as fuck bitch.
Why would you wish that's what somebody,
you don't know.
There's this real sad,
maybe it's in my head.
Go down.
Might be a little fit.
Never claimed to be steady.
Oh,
she real black.
She's,
she blacker than me.
She tapped the MIPS in.
This bitch is black.
I mean you,
what?
Can you say what a white girl got?
She got this bitch.
How clone some nickel.
Yeah,
she's on cloud as lady.
She played,
I mean she got the neck twist and look at a lymph node we were talking about.
That's just how familiar and like how she,
yeah,
she more than Black Dick.
Yeah,
right.
I see it on Steve.
Sanjay and I don't see nasty bitch ass.
What the other one that I forgot.
I forgot her name.
You ever live in any way?
But I see.
Okay,
fine too.
I don't care what race you are,
Babe.
I'm not racist.
Them bitches just got me fucked up.
But it's just the black bitches that's talking.
So that's why I said black bitches.
Do you think she's ever,
that's probably why she's talking shit like this because she's never had a
fight.
Like she's never had her ass.
What she gonna know?
She gonna get her ass beat.
She don't get her now she will.
He probably going to beat her ass.
Well,
it just amaze me because I'm looking at a white girl,
but I'm hearing a system.
Right?
I mean she got the demeanor all down so she,
she could really play that.
That game.
I play with you
when you cheated on me,
but I mean she would really fool people,
right?
Yeah,
she will.
She got it down.
But
bitches in this group.
No.
Hmm.
Wait.
So,
okay,
so this is the debate is like,
she culturally,
that's like a Rachel Dole is all,
yeah,
that whole bag of worms.
Okay.
Culturally,
she identifies this way,
but is it ever okay?
No,
it's never.
Okay.
Because if she was standing in a group and don't care how much you my friend,
you cannot,
you can't say that.
You think she would?
Uh,
no,
no.
Let me tell you something about when the white people say nigger.
Honestly we feel it.
I mean it's like no.
Listen,
we feel it.
Like if you,
if you stuck your hand on a hot stove for some reason when it comes out of a
concave,
Caucasian mouth,
anybody other than black,
like we do it just a throwaway.
But when you say he hurt it fucking hurts.
I totally believe you.
I totally believe now she's all black.
I don't feel it.
No.
But you think,
would you say that hurt the hurt thing?
Like I totally believe that.
Do you feel like it's different when somebody,
does it hurt when somebody is trying to,
trying to appropriate and like drop it casually like,
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
Like when when someone drops it like that,
you still feel,
you still feel like pain,
her contact she,
that would be that.
What you're saying.
Yeah.
You will see that will upset and be like,
what are you doing that,
yeah.
Yeah.
It was like,
it will be,
we will,
it will feel like race racism.
Yes.
We will feel it casually.
I mean if you're doing it me,
no matter what we feel it.
Yeah.
And it's crazy.
It is crazy.
And I think he's just passed down through our ancestral,
through slave.
We feel that pain from that word and you know,
we have,
I have shit to do with slavery,
but it's just,
it's automatically hate when it comes out of somebody else's mouth.
And I think the reason why we say it so much because it was sad,
tall ancestor so much and it was saying to,
you know,
in the 60s and stuff to hurt her so much.
Now we finally got control of the word.
Sure.
Yeah.
And now you saying nobody ever told white people they can't say it.
It's not just the law to say it.
I guess after enough margin and ass kicking wipe you,
she doesn't realize well we don't go and let y'all had it were,
well some of them,
some of them,
some of them.
The way we go in now with our administration is free to do whatever the hell you
want to do even.
Oh God.
That's what I just thought.
But I based the low,
lower my mom and Laura.
What's her accent?
Where is she from?
What part?
Like not Atlanta
tend to see Alabama.
Alabama.
I heard Atlanta,
but yeah,
she could be Georgia too.
She's a diva.
She Dee Dee.
What I was telling her was that I thought if she lived in Georgia,
she lived like 40 miles outside of Atlanta.
You know like she lived.
No,
she could be right down in the west end where I grew up at.
I mean she got the demeanor,
the nic road,
that's how they talk nail.
So South Fast Lik you know,
so many words you said.
I'm like,
what?
Let me,
so she got
the I rap song,
you know it's happening.
I can understand tiyaga sunlight,
Migos.
I'm like,
I don't know how to say that to me goes are saying that all my Sabi recognize
shit.
I'm like,
you repping this shit but you found a high school graduation test that shit out.
I read with the Migos.
I Sat,
I don't know what the fuck they just mean neither
bad and boozy.
I was like,
what the fuck is bad and boozy?
What is bad and Boujee Ashley?
No,
just be bad and and wealthy.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that the Amigos things a phenomenon to me.
I don't even know you guys are talking about
[inaudible] had his fucking little rappers in the world.
Damn stuck in the ninety's is a different level of white to me.
Not that you need,
I'm white too.
I got health care.
I feel you Christine.
I don't be like,
turn that shit off of what Michael Jackson.
Fuck it.
I listen to Art Kelly.
Oh my God.
I really be peed on in the man.
I had to bull shit.
You know what the fuck they just say.
Who's that guy we used to play all the time.
No,
no,
no.
He was a rapper too.
And he always had wisdom.
You're talking about,
and I'm calm.
I mean,
I mean on the show.
Oh,
software only now only.
It was very,
very drawl.
He you couldn't understand and we would try to figure out what he was talking
about.
Oh God.
You know what I mean?
He's on my pussy a lot too.
And you're talking about plot?
Yes.
Oh,
he,
he got it.
He got an Instagram account.
I want to be nice to have course.
I want to treat that.
Plus I like,
Gosh,
that was that
do on the bus.
That's
how much black people can cook.
They plus seasons saw owned a buzzy,
why people don't even put seasoned salt on a chicken,
you say?
Yeah,
that's the most horrible shit you can eat.
We became barbecue once.
She,
but it'd be decorated.
It'd be,
I went to a white barbecue and that she was laying,
I said,
would he move and white photo on there?
So what the fuck y'all cook meat with?
No.
Fucking see is how are we doing wrong?
And used to be,
oh my God,
it ain't shit.
Don't now.
So now when I go to white barbecue,
I just bring my own seat and on my phone when I ain't,
don't Cook my shit,
I'm going to season it up and throw it on the grill.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
Yeah,
for sure.
Can I ask you a question about present real quick?
Yeah.
Was it at all like orange is the new black
is DV Miche and Steve,
when I was in jail,
I tell you,
when I was in jail it was this a Moffa die.
And so you gotta remember I was like 1819 and Notifica Moffa dyke was what was a
thing with a little wieners.
The little,
the little cliques and done grew out,
you know,
they call him off.
I'm fucking up to her because I was fucking words.
So she,
I walked in the room one day and she would eat and digging her down with a
little dick and I said,
they ate so much pussy in jail.
Oh my God.
If you one gay day was going to turn you gay,
they didn't fuck with me because I fought all the time.
I fought.
All the guards were calling eating each other out.
No,
they ate.
It was so much pussy eating and now I'm telling you you can't.
It will.
It blew me away.
I didn't even know really know what gay women did on TV.
I got to prison.
Really?
You walk in a room with one,
got another one in the both for teenagers in each somebody else's mouth.
Y'All just cool with this.
This is a good way to kill time.
I,
I couldn't get on.
They put,
they give you that Koolaid shit and they put this shit to keep your vagina from
jumping around.
But that shit didn't have,
you know they give you that drink.
They keep you from getting horny wage came out.
Yeah.
They give you,
they put something in your drink because why does it keep you from getting in
women's prisons?
Yeah.
Women and men.
That's shit he need.
You ever heard of?
Yeah.
It must not have been drinking enough of that shit man.
They will eat and each other to death.
That's the thing that bothered me more because it was nothing to you.
You will have somebody watch out and they will go at it.
They had origins and everything I was in,
I was in,
my roommate was a crackhead that I used to,
she was in jail.
She kept going to Jeff,
a prostituted in drugs so she could sing her ass off.
But the WHO and that bitch got clean.
She's the same Meta sleep every night.
Whitney,
Mary j Blige.
That bitch could say,
I got to tell you this story is kind of gross.
So we love growth.
Look.
So I had never used a tampon in my life.
Right.
So in jail they give you tampons,
more tampons and pads.
So I was like,
I don't know how to use the templates.
So you share your room with your woman?
I don't stop the court ball and their family and I'm walking off.
Oh my hurts so bad that my roommate was like,
I was wondering when you going to take the core board I cause that's,
she said I saw you when you put it in there,
but I didn't want to tell you what
now
I was,
oh my,
my thing was beat up like I had been at my thing on my back,
like plies.
We seasoned salt plus plus and my policy was beat up.
Now how about the shower situation?
I'm not talking about getting raped and share.
I'm talking about like there,
there's no doors on the stalls and that show and it seems like you had to go
shower at like five in the morning so that people will fuck with you.
Was it like that,
you know,
they wouldn't ripen them or nothing like that.
You,
you saw,
you saw girls taking showers together,
but it wasn't nothing.
He,
they,
they'll,
what they did,
but they left you alone.
Were you locked up a year?
I,
uh,
I will go in that bitch with my uniform on my dirty uniform and washed up on
here and my vagina and then go to my room.
Put on my dress shit.
Oh really?
I was just not comfortable because they used to have this thing where when you,
when you a newt,
when you come in to jail,
he'd be like,
trucks up,
trucks up.
That mean you look good and somebody was going to eat yo.
So every time a new load of cheese come up,
trucks up and they'd be upstairs picking them up down that one,
that one,
that slang to start using works up trucks up pretty ladies walked by trucks.
Yeah,
they would,
they would yell at trucks up.
So how did you avoid getting wifed up?
Like it's not,
it's not,
that's what it seems like it happens in women.
I wasn't gay.
I wasn't getting you was not sucking on my hands.
And you know,
I had a real ghetto baby daddy day.
We'll make you call on Jesus.
He couldn't read,
but he can fuck.
I ain't gone lie.
He couldn't read a leak.
Y'All were getting lost.
Got One.
No gps begging them days and he couldn't read the street signs,
but he could,
he could.
He could make love.
There you go.
Yeah,
he sucked his thumb too,
but
it was like a,
I don't know,
he's still sucking to Nep rollerskating.
He'd be rolling scale.
He's a fucking gay.
Your Daddy?
Yeah,
he's so gay.
He said pump arms on his roller skates.
Pompom with the little bell
ringing bell.
They get more young girls.
Well he loved this guy.
He suck his thumb.
Oh my God,
it was dom is a boxer rock.
I remember when we got locked up one time when shooting craps and I jumped the
fence and he jumped the physical,
he could run his ass.
He could've been a track star and I got stuck on the fence and I couldn't get
over.
So he came to pull me down and we all got arrested.
And so we go to court one day after,
after I clean up my life,
the case came back and we had to go to court.
So he called me all these fat bitches and shit.
So I,
you know,
I wasn't even at me.
Oh,
you're fat bitch.
You showing that.
Why the judge?
They didn't know.
So I said,
I'm going to get this dumb motherfucker.
I waited till it.
The lady come in,
she said,
y'all sign these papers.
Y'All going to get probation
as,
excuse me,
you all this Nigga Camry,
he only can sign x is
wow.
Court rule fell out laughing.
I said,
I got your ass good,
grabbed my keys and walked up out of there.
Nice.
He's,
you know what's crazy?
He is still mad.
He,
I talked to him a couple of weeks ago.
He's like,
I don't have no relationship with my son because of,
because you ran off and left me and I said,
dude,
you beat me.
You shot me pieces.
She gave me gonna ruin craps and fleas.
I supposed to keep sticking around air fryer to get punched in and left.
I got to grow up one day.
I didn't know until I don't have a relationship with my son and he won't even
call me.
I said,
well he going to call you.
but you ride the bus and every time he tried to talk to you a background is too
loud so you should wait till you get a call.
It's when your background is,
you know,
a lot more quieter so he can understand what the fuck you saying.
You don't want your son around a guy that's abuse of anyways.
Alright,
well my son not knowing,
my husband raised him and he said,
I try but I don't have nothing to talk to him about.
All my son is remember as a pair of shoes he never bought.
I don't even remember these shoes.
He said,
Dude told me going to buy me a pair of a pair of cleats for football and he
never bought him so,
but he always said I took his keys away and she lived in Atlanta.
I'm like,
call her,
don't worry about it.
He's just guilty.
That's what,
that's what crappy people do.
They make you feel like shit for stuff that you shouldn't feel like shit for.
You know what I mean?
Did he know somehow I'm going to sue you when his book came out,
I said,
dude,
you can't read.
First of all,
I'm not really much for me.
And I said,
if you do,
you're behind.
You're been on behind on your child support since I know so there you go.
You're going to sue me.
They're going to cut me a check right back,
so please sue me.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
he's like a door and he's ain't doing,
I'm not worried about that claim.
All want to pay to send you to a seminar.
Would you consider going to this if we,
you know we have,
we set up the whole thing.
Are you serious?
I was just wanting to share.
There are many ways to orgasm.
What the fuck?
Just from,
they're having a hug orgasm and we want to send you to their seminar and then
you come back and give us,
we'll send a camera crew and you try to full weekend.
You learn how to come hug though.
You don't want to learn.
Come home.
Wait.
Now what caliber of white people are these days?
Take another stupid ass white people.
Money.
Absolutely.
Black pastors
wants to give them money to send you to the coast.
I don't know yet,
but I'm willing to pay whatever it is.
You want to go to the comma.
When you hug people near you.
Calm.
She got a new girlfriend.
I call a big foot.
Big Foot.
Well you and big foot go.
She got a big old beast.
She begging out Brian,
Jackie,
how long have you been with big Ashley?
Oh,
she don't have a claim on we're dating.
We're not in a relationship.
I'm like,
come on dude.
Once you get the vagina,
you go together.
Well,
lesbians,
from what I understand,
it moves pretty quickly to have a new one every thanksgiving.
And I tried to tell the new one this time.
I said,
if you don't make it at three Thanksgiving and you don't count,
we don't even lock their phones,
you know,
till they make it.
It three things get.
And I literally have no lesbians numbers locked in my phone.
She get rid of all of them.
Wow.
One thanksgiving.
Good for her.
She's he Ashley's young.
She's still,
you know,
figuring it out.
I said,
you're such a slut who is just like your real daddy.
You just got so many holes
cranky.
I would like for her to use off of John and the right way.
You know this is part of life,
right?
She's young.
Beautiful.
She's doing her thing right now.
She needed to get married and that's why everybody's 31
oh happy birthday.
You should.
You should settle down.
You should get married.
He's people don't fault for your rights.
I mean it was like black people not vote.
Not at the holiday shit.
They don't ski that model,
the king down the street and shit.
That man did all of that shit.
That's true.
I had to keep from laughing when I said they skied him
on
getting them down the road.
So I mean gay shit up y'all.
This gay stuff,
they fight for their rights.
You should be getting married.
I mean they fought to so she can get married.
Get married already.
Come on.
Yeah,
get married to have some plastic babies.
I won't play.
She'll do it.
Yeah.
What's wrong with foot?
What if they were big foot?
Would that be okay?
I don't care who it is.
It's a big fruit guy.
She said she's going to get married one day.
I don't know.
I'm telling you is almost buddy.
She ain't no good.
Oh,
oh
no.
Hey,
I saw the Po is passed.
We were just following her lead.
Don't be on the phone while got her big foot's you'll like me to call him
bigfoot,
Huh?
She knows the trick now.
I'll do like big foot.
Oh Shit.
Well she's not going to last.
We just wrecked a family.
Tammy.
Sorry.
Almost off.
Okay.
Asked him,
will you ever date your mom?
We found um,
of a mother and son that got married.
Yeah.
You line will show you this and then now these aren't what?
I'm your mom and you're my son and I followed him.
Are you really?
I said,
yes,
I am.
He's thinking,
you know what,
I was scared to let you know too.
I am too,
both consenting adults.
If it comes down to it,
you know,
it's just like the gate there,
as long as they're over 18 or what is their race?
What race or nationality or Latino's for shame.
God,
yeah,
yeah.
Not why,
but they,
they could me,
you know what I mean?
And their actions kind of stupid.
Latinas are great for making babies but not with your Mama.
And I was not good.
And they let,
they let them get married and I got it.
They got arrested,
they went to get married.
I went to jail or they went to jail.
They should have went to jail.
She should've been,
should've been timeless.
Absolutely crazy.
That's crazy.
Deep people cry.
You know the funniest thing I love telling this.
Dot.
I don't know if I ever told you,
but this lady,
it was a,
it was in Atlanta.
So this lady tried to help this black kid,
a black lady,
get his life back together.
So she said,
well you cleaned the kiln.
Kiln those with my dog and take care of my pit bulls and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna help you pay for your GED.
I'm gonna pay for your GED and get you back on,
right Trey.
Well,
next door neighbor film till fucking a pit bull pit bull.
So the police came to the door.
I said,
well,
does he had been doing to your dog and the lady saying,
so how to say the dog's name
is Amy Holly.
I peed on myself.
Fucking good.
Nice,
awesome.
Low down motherfucker fucking fuck them.
She's like,
oh my God,
they're going to need counseling.
Counseling.
That is a mobile internet.
It's crazy.
What is wrong with you people?
I
know Mary,
the mom and mental,
Ya'll funny shit.
Everybody sends it in.
People send it in.
They should've locked.
Oh,
she's doing time.
I,
yeah,
I think she is.
I mean,
she probably touched him as a kid.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Oh,
somebody touched her that yes,
she's touched.
Definitely just scare you.
Did people put a kid out in the world and I've been exposed to all these crazy
think about it and thinking it constantly.
How fucked up most of humanity is.
Yeah.
The time.
It's dead.
It's terrifying.
You know?
I have all,
I have for my,
I have my niece custody of my niece for kids from age four to nine now she's on
drugs.
She ran off and left them and when I first got these kids four years ago and um,
they had been exposed to so much bullshit job when you come out of the hood and
the messed up situation you have PTSD for sure.
I'm telling you these kids would tidy shoes real tight and I will take him to
the playground and my community and I said why y'all got y'all shoes tied so
tight and was like we might have the knock Mario.
I said not in this fucking commune on tie your shoes.
They will say the craziest stuff.
They're like in a war zone.
They was ready to beat them white keys and said that Paul and I was like you
won't got to do that then shit I stuff with you.
It took about a year,
like she would go to school and they would call me all the time,
you need to come up here cause my,
my niece who told her white and that she's the only black kid in her class and
they sit around talking about their parents.
She's like,
Ooh,
I can't wait to get my daddy to get out of jail cause I'm a stab him in the,
Nate
was in first grade.
They called me up.
That a principle we need to talk to you.
I said,
white people,
y'all gotta calm down and if the kid's been through some shit and that's all
they know how to fuck up their pairs,
it's going to get,
is everything good?
Is going to get better.
Fuck me.
That is so good.
Now let's,
uh,
so people know what date does the book come out of?
The book is called Rabbit Autobiography of Miss Pat.
August 22nd.
And I'm doing a big book signing that mortise and in Indianapolis,
right?
Club.
Uh Huh.
Oh,
oh yeah.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
I'm doing a book signing August 25th,
August 26.
So please go out and get your tickets is going to be fun along with the m four
shows.
Great.
I'm so excited for
having me back guys.
True.
So fun.
You're so talented and you deserve every,
every bit of your success and we're rooting for you and,
and sell millions of books.
Well,
I hope so.
Y'All,
come on.
Let's read.
If you don't know how to read,
you have until August 22nd,
some.
Learn to let shit heard me reading the audio book.
Oh my God.
I can't wait for that.
Yeah.
I was a book signing at mortise August 25th,
26.
Great,
great.
Are you going to perform to perform to,
it's a show too,
so you can get a book.
You can get it sign and then you can watch me do comedy.
That's awesome.
Very happy for you,
Miss Pat.
Thank you so very much.
Thank you.
All right guys,
thanks for listening to the show and,
um,
a,
make sure you check out Miss Pat's new book.
Talk to you later.
We'll see you next week.
Call.
Tell him
rabbit,
dry rub,
rub,
rub.
There's a lot of stuff
come dripping from your beard
or a pink sheep.
She,
Yep.